las declaraciones del presidente de
Brasil Lula da Silva donde
responsabilizó accidente de propiciar la
continuidad de la guerra en Ucrania
encendieron las tensiones con Estados
Unidos el portavoz de la Casa Blanca
John Kirby respondió este lunes a los
comentarios del brasileño a quien acusó
de repetir el discurso ruso
es profundamente problemática la forma
en la que Brasil ha abordado este tema
tanto de manera sustantiva como de
manera retórica al sugerir que Estados
Unidos y Europa de alguna manera no
están interesados en La Paz o que
comparten responsabilidad por la guerra
en ese punto Brasil está repitiendo como
el oro la propaganda rusa y China sin
prestar atención en absoluto a los
hechos luego de reunirse con el ministro
de exteriores rusos el canciller
brasileño módulo vieira expresó su
desacuerdo
No para nada no estoy para nada de
acuerdo no sé cómo llegaron a esa
conclusión en absoluto quién lo dijo
quién fue Quién fue
Bueno eso es todo No lo sé no sé las
razones por las que dijo eso
encontrar partida Brasil ha recibido el
agradecimiento de la broma a quien
destacó la comprensión del gobierno de
Lula
en cuanto a los procesos en Ucrania
estamos agradecidos con nuestros amigos
brasileños por su excelente comprensión
de la Génesis de esta situación y
estamos agradecidos por su deseo de
contribuir a la búsqueda de formas de
resolverlo
Brasil se ha mantenido Imparcial en el
conflicto desde el comienzo de la guerra
desde la Asunción de Lula el mandatario
se ha mostrado como un mediador
fomentando el diálogo sin embargo el
interés de Brasil por los fertilizantes
rusos y su reciente acercamiento a China
su principal socio comercial han
generado roces con la Casa Blanca